Before I start, I'd like to know
who's in charge today?
Is it me?
Is it you?
Is it someone behind the curtain?
My point is, we think of leadership
as a role for the few
and the rest get to just lean back.
Now, that, of course, might be OK
for an event like this,
but I believe that leadership by the few,
it's not going to help us solve
the problems ahead.
These problems are complex
and coming at us faster and faster.
So we really need to get
many minds together,
more resources, more capabilities,
and we need to do it
effectively and sustainably.
What if leadership could be for the many?
That's scary.
And for all you leaders out there
thinking it won't work,
maybe in some cases it won't.
But when it does, we have better
outcomes and happier people,
with everyone leaning in,
even if just a bit more.
I'm a physicist turned
management consultant
working with global companies on strategy,
artificial intelligence
and digital transformation.
I'm trained as an engineer,
so when I started in this job,
everything was new to me.
And I have to admit something.
At work, whenever a task is my idea,
I do it a bit better
than when it's someone else telling me.
(Laughter)
Unless, of course, it's my boss.
Then I might feel like slowly
proving it doesn't work.
(Laughter)
Being curious and complacent, I often ask:
Why do we do things this way?
Most times I do find good answers,
but whenever the answers seem outdated,
I try to come up with new solutions.
Like with leadership.
A typical view of leadership
is a hierarchical organization chart.
Either you're a leader or you're not.
Most people are being led,
not taking lead.
Communication often flows from top
to bottom along just one line,
which means it doesn't match
the complexity of problems
which move in several directions at once.
Decisions are left
to one person, the leader,
who, being only human,
can become a bottleneck
of speed and scale.
They can miss new ideas,
diverse capabilities and potential
that exist all over the chart.
So in a network instead,
everyone's in charge
and we replace power of the few
with influence of the many.
Sure it looks more messy,
but I'd argue more beautiful,
more multi-dimensional,
more dynamic, more like nature.
I believe this model can help us do more
and be less dependent on each individual.
Which means it’s resilient,
and progress is sustainable.
To empower many more to lead,
to move leadership
from the few to the many,
we each need to let go of a bit of power.
Now that's uncomfortable.
So let's talk about how.
The first thing we can do
is remove labels.
Now, imagine your co-worker,
Lin, says "We need creative input."
And Joe goes, "Let's ask accounting."
(Laughter)
Said no one, ever.
But maybe we should.
Labels take many forms and shapes
like functions, titles,
genders, nationalities,
educational backgrounds.
They are everywhere
and help us recognize things.
And sometimes we even
work hard to get that label,
so they are comfortable.
But labels come with a high
cost of boxing people in,
not enabling us to grow
outside those boxes.
We need to think about diverse skill sets
and perspectives as we set teams.
But once we have,
what if you for a second forgot
who's from marketing
or who's the data scientist
or who's the leader?
I have at least been amazed
by surprising capabilities in our teams.
You don't know what you don't know.
Well, you also don't know
what others know.
Accounting might actually have
a great marketing idea.
Now that we have gotten
rid of those labels,
I have another uncomfortable idea for you.
Share everything.
We've learned to share a lot of things
like rides, scooters, even our homes.
But when it comes to work,
we so often end up sitting
on information and resources
for ourselves.
And have you ever thought to yourself:
“I can’t ask that, it’s too stupid?”
Yeah?
Or maybe you've tried
withholding information
thinking it would give you an advantage?
(Laughter)
Or, you know, the feeling of,
"Had I just known that,
I would have done so much better."
Let's imagine a team working together
on a green transition strategy,
and the following conversation
is inspired by a team I was part of.
And Amine says he's working on a list
of emission reduction levers.
He's stuck, asking for help.
Isabelle goes,
"Do you have this data set?"
Lisa: "Oh, stated something similar.
Shall we combine?"
Peter: "Another market
worked on this - did you meet?"
This is leadership.
Not in the hierarchical sense,
but in the sense of taking lead
for solving a problem
by listing questions and involving people.
Leadership is not about giving answers.
It is asking the questions.
It is daring to show vulnerability.
Information is power
and information is everything,
like questions, but also data,
context, emerging insights,
work in progress,
even water cooler conversations.
Sharing means less
one-on-one communication,
much more crowdsourcing and co-creation
in the open, transparent space,
real time.
And with more upheaval
than you might naturally think of.
Wait.
Doesn't that get really
messy, even chaotic?
Well, we are used to information
overload already.
I’m guessing you don’t read
everything on social media,
and you know quickly how to navigate
your way to what's relevant to you.
And if you catch yourself thinking,
“I can’t share that,”
I want you to test again and ask, why?
Because the upside of sharing
everything is huge.
We can leverage the power of the crowd
much better when we all have context.
It's faster due to less waste
and duplicate work
and conflicting input in one-on-ones.
But also because we can parallelize work
and not just work sequentially.
It drives better quality
when we capture ideas day and night
and when we distribute quality assurance
across the full team.
But the best of it all,
we get greater ownership
through early involvement
of people like customers and stakeholders,
avoiding that classic show-and-tell,
the one-way presentation.
You can probably tell
I could go on and on,
but there is one more
uncomfortable thing we have to do.
Be nice to each other.
(Laughter)
Kindness.
Sure, you say.
But in the moment, isn't it easier
throwing someone else under the bus?
And have you tried the opposite of kind,
the unkind leader,
the one who happily shares
blame but not shine?
Or the pretend kind leader.
Like, “I know it’s Friday afternoon,
and I need this by Monday 8 am.
But don't spend your weekend on it."
(Laughter)
Kind or unkind becomes especially clear
when someone makes a mistake.
Now take Sara, she spotted a mistake,
a quite significant one.
Now Sara is brave and shares that
instantly with the full team.
Wow, the replies.
Bharat goes, "Thanks for sharing.
That takes courage."
Samuel, "Better now than never."
Jenny, "No mistakes would mean
we weren't moving fast enough."
The formal leaders in this conversation,
they didn't think much
about it when this happened,
but the team members have later come back
and said that this was a truly defining
moment for the team culture.
They felt safe, a sense of growth mindset
and trust that we have each other's back.
The team members
also encourage each other,
whether it's "love it,"
"spot on" or cute emojis.
This matters.
People so often roll their eyes
when we talk about kindness,
but even small words go a long way.
This doesn't mean lowering the bar
or avoiding difficult conversation.
In fact, kindness allows us
to take up even trickier topics.
And the results?
Well, good projects
deliver on time as expected.
Honestly, I think we all know
projects that really don't.
But by removing labels,
sharing everything and being kind,
you started seeing a spike.
Though more bumpy,
we now get exponential growth.
Results are much better and unexpected.
Like the team I introduced you to.
People couldn't believe the impact
and ownership we created.
In just eight weeks.
And we've seen this
across many different problems
and very different desired outcomes.
Changing how we work,
we found amazing results.
Even early on in pilots,
80 percent of our people said
they experienced more value delivered.
Sixty percent found better individual
sustainability, work-life balance.
And this is in a company
known for high-performing teams.
When everyone is a leader,
it allows us to do more and do it better.
Now imagine we took the formal
leader out of the team.
That's in fact, what happened as I went
on maternity leave a few months back.
Nothing happened.
The team just went on.
Even this talk, I didn't come up
with the ideas on my own.
Many people did.
It was crowdsourced
and co-created from day one.
Distributed leadership is a movement
that goes beyond the traditional leader.
People are much more likely to do things
if they feel a sense of ownership
and "it was my idea"
versus being told what to do.
We need to create leaders, not followers.
Now, none of this is magic,
but it won't happen
if traditional leaders block it.
We can't afford having anyone
sitting back these days
with complex problems coming at us
quickly and constantly.
We need to tap into everyone's
knowledge and creativity.
Labels and hierarchies,
hiding information, consolidating power,
being unkind or pretend kind.
That's not going to help us do
what we need to
to create a better future.
So when I now ask you,
who's in charge,
who’s the leader today?
I want you all to raise your hands.
(Laughter)
Yes, you.
Thank you.
(Applause)